hello I believe that we are live so this
is my my second ever YouTube broadcast
so hello welcome everybody this year is
Sienna behind me I've got I've got Ruby
who's asleep she might start snoring
during the presentation these two dogs
like a snore a lot so that's always fun
I've got my live chat open here so I can
actually watch you guys on my phone so
hopefully I'll be able to interact a
little bit more with you today than last
time last time was my first experiment
so today we're going to talk about the
evolution of new functions and so that's
pretty exciting I'm gonna start sharing
my screen here and I've got some slides
that I've prepared for you
mmm screen share yeah where you going
okay
this tunnel of my screen okay so we're
gonna talk about the fitzroy river
turtle and its amazing ability to
breathe through its butt and we're gonna
talk about how that evolved and we're
gonna talk about how new functions
evolve in general and you know new new
organs new structures we're gonna learn
how it is that those things evolve and
I'm gonna be doing a question-and-answer
section I'm actually gonna do two of
them throughout this presentation so if
you've got some questions save those for
the question-and-answer time otherwise
you know feel free to chat about
whatever in the comment section so long
as you are you know being nice to each
other
keep them things PG so today no here on
my slides I'm gonna do a Q&A halfway
through and then again at the end
super chats our priority I don't know if
you know much about super chats but that
allows you to like uh you know throw a
little bit of money my way and it makes
it so that I can see your comment at the
very top of all the comments so if you
have a question that you really want to
be answered
stupid chats or priority but I'll answer
pretty much any question that I can find
in the during the Q&A and be nice to
people in the comments and I'm gonna try
to keep this presentation PG you know
it's kind of I'm near to this and yeah
that's my goal evolution of course is
well it's evolution is about survival
and reproduction so sometimes things do
get a little bit adult in these
conversations so but yeah I'll try and
keep it PG okay so
today's question comes from Peter and
Peter actually he wrote me a very
excited email a little on September 5th
asking a whole bunch of questions and
one of which was how does function come
about from non function and just so you
know just kind of like a basic tip for
anybody who's trying to get someone to
respond to them by email that they don't
actually know personally I recommend
keeping things short and very succinct
in emails if you're emailing someone
that you don't really know that well
actually I recommend doing that anytime
you write an email we've kind of got to
this point in our culture where we don't
we don't really think about emails we
just send them because it's cheap and
easy to send one right but we really
should be more careful and considerate
in our correspondence with other people
if I were trying to ask a question from
a researcher that I didn't know I would
I would first of all read everything the
researcher has has done and go to their
website I figure out all the stuff that
they get they do the things that they
teach and I'd only ask a question that
is not already directly addressed by
their work so most of the questions that
he wrote here are already directly
addressed by videos that I have on the
stated clearly channel which he hasn't
watched yet so in the future advice to
anyone asking questions of anyone else
in the scientific community or you know
on YouTube actually read their stuff
first
watch their stuff first and then ask
questions afterwards so this is this is
one of the questions he had in here that
was very legitimate how does function
come about from non function that's
something I don't really address in my
videos so I'm going to address that
today I guess I sort of do but so yeah
I'm going to respond to that question
here so how does new function evolve
well there's kind of three ways that
we've we've seen new functions evolve
and first of all is gradually each step
along the way being beneficial to the
organisms survival and reproduction and
we also have what we call hopeful
monsters this is a term coined by
Stephen Jay Gould to talk about these
kind of big mutations that happen that
really change an animal's function and
form and usually the first individual
the that undergoes a big mutation is
kind of messed up but they might have a
big enough of an advantage that they can
survive and reproduce and maybe even
sometimes be better at surviving and
reproducing than their neighbors because
that hopeful mutation was was so good
but oftentimes it comes with a bunch of
weird little disabilities that have to
get worked out over time over
evolutionary time and then third is
exaptation and I'll talk about that in a
second but I want to show you with dogs
the examples of a gradual step by step
change in form and then the kind of
hopeful monster type change in form and
let me go back to my camera here my my
dog starting to snore let me go stop
sharing my screen hey wake up whoa so
sorry so this here is an example of a
hopeful monster the mutation that
flattened this is a these these dog
breeds that have flat faces the mutation
that flattened their faces it's
something that really happened for the
most part all at once a fairly simple
mutation that causes the skull to do
this but as a result they have a very
flat face and they have some
disabilities because of this like you
just heard her snoring
that's a result of that mutation are you
doing it by to sleep so here I've got a
wolf
skull it's kind of blown out the
Lighting's a little bit too bright in
here for my webcam here but
is a wolf skull and then this is a skull
actually of a French French Bulldog and
you can see that huge difference the
huge difference happened pretty much all
at once and as a result of that the
teeth are kind of messed up but the big
benefit of this mutation is that humans
think it's cute
and because dogs currently live in an
environment full of humans that want to
take care of them
being cute is a huge survival advantage
if you are a dog so even though this
mutation causes some breathing problems
and causes some some teeth problems the
fact that these little flat she doesn't
want to be on camera anymore apparently
I'm disturbing her sleep the fact that
these flat faces are are so cute to
humans makes it a huge advantage for
them so back to my slides here
so another
a good example of a gradual something
that would work gradually so where every
step along the way is a benefit we've
got if you look at a chicken's feet you
can see that they've kind of got a
little bit of webbing between their toes
and you look at a duck and they've got a
lot of webbing and this actually could
have happened in a hopeful monster type
scenario where you had a mutation that
caused a lot of webbing between the toes
but it also could have happened in a
gradual step-by-step manner where you
have a little bit of webbing developing
and then more and more and more until
you have something like a duck's foot
and this would be selected for in an
environment where there's a lot of water
and you've got the the selected new
selective advantage of having webbed
feet and this could happen gradually
every step along the way being slightly
beneficial or again could have happened
all at once this is another example of
the completely different form of webbed
feet this is an a bird called the
American coot which is also on aquatic
bird and it instead of having webbing
between the toes actually just flattened
out its toes there's these scales that
hang off the the pose there which is
really cool so those are the three types
of ways that new functions evolve and
the third is exaptation that's where an
old trait is used for a new function so
when a trait or organ starts being used
for a second function one for which it
did not originally evolve that's what we
call an exaptation this word by the way
was also coined by Stephen Jay Gould he
did a lot of you know
conceptual work and evolutionary biology
this here is a leaf and you can see the
veins of the leaf there this here is a
different type of leaf this is from a
bull thistle and you can see that the
spikes I mean this is the kind of way
that you get in your yard and it's a
huge pain in the butt to take care of
because it's got these giant spikes on
it and you can see that it's weapons
it's the
Spike's actually evolved from just veins
and the leaf veins which were already
being used to carry nutrients to and
from the the leaves nutrients and sugar
you know that the leaves are producing
sugar and that sugar is going back out
to the plant through these through these
veins and in this plant just by
extending past the margin of the leaf
and drying out those veins developed a
brand new function one which did not
exist before and that is this ability to
be a a weapon so and it's quite a
formidable weapon too there's actually I
believe in this plant there's also
toxins that have you've all the you
could say the the blood of the plant
because when you get when you get
pricked by one of these it actually
hurts for quite a while it's like kind
of like getting stung might as bad as
getting stung by a bee but it's it's it
does irritate you this here oh it's open
it would play looks like it doesn't want
to play on on on my slides here but this
bird is kind of going through an
exaptation here this is a you can find
this on YouTube there's this bird that
well use its fallen feathers as back
scratchers what he's doing right there
is he's kind of tuned on the end of it
and then he'll he'll put it behind his
feathers and scratches little head with
it so there's organisms are constantly
developing new new functions new new
acceptations
as time goes on so this here is kind of
a
list of different traits that evolved
through exaptation you know it's a lot
of times when we find a trait that
evolved as an exaptation it's really
hard for us to figure out how it evolved
because they're really complex
structures and the reason for that is if
they had you know when we looked at the
knee webbed feet and ducks it's pretty
easy to see how that could have evolved
in a kind of a straight path but when
exaptation occur evolution occurs in
this weird zig zaggy path and it can be
really difficult to actually pinpoint
how a particular structure evolved so
the bacterial flagellum has been used by
creationists for for a while now to say
that Oh something like this could not
have evolved and the reason they say
that is they say that it's irreducibly
complex and that it could not have
evolved in a straight line where each
slight variation is beneficial for the
organism and that is true the bacterial
flagellum could not have evolved in a
straight line but there's a lot of
evidence suggesting that it evolved from
the type 3 secretion system so bacteria
like to inject molecules into other
cells and they do that through this type
3 secretion system and when we look at
the bacterial flagellum all the proteins
that it's made of almost all of them
come from this type 3 secretion system
and it's just a slight modification of
that system that gives you this
flagellum this thing that can kind of
spin around and act as a motor sorry I
probably should explain that the
bacterial flagellum is a motor on
bacteria they used to swim with it's a
little tail and it's it's a very
complicated structure and it involved as
an exaptation from the type 3 secretion
system feathers on birds evolved from
the conical scales of reptiles and our
knowledge of this comes from studying
how the feathers develop on a bird I'll
have to do another talk sometime where I
show all that because that's that's a
lot of fun to look at actually I believe
I have an old talk
on this static Ashleigh Channel how did
flight evolve which goes over that
briefly flight feathers evolved from
insulation feathers so the earliest
feathers were not used for flight
they're used for insulation bird wings
are modified arms so they have evolved
from arms and you can actually see the
hand bones the finger bones their wrist
bones in a in a bird's wing the heart
you know we have this incredible heart
very complicated structure and when we
look back through evolutionary time
mainly in this case because hearts don't
fossilize well when we look at
comparative anatomy we see that the
heart appears to have evolved from
muscle vessels so in very small
organisms small organisms living in the
ocean where they get a lot of their
their oxygen and you know they do a lot
of their chemical exchange just through
their skin they don't really need a
heart because there's such small animals
surrounded by liquid living in the water
they they don't really need a full heart
and our ancient ancestors were such
organisms and as they began to get
larger and more complex and they needed
in order to get larger you need to
distribute some sort of a blood type
substance that can help exchange gases
throughout the body
you had these vessels develop and then
you had muscles around those vessels
developed that could squeeze that liquid
and kind of slosh it through the body
and as as that system got more and more
efficient the organism the organisms
were able to evolve larger body size and
more complex body size until eventually
you have the evolution of a thing like a
heart lungs appear to have evolved from
gill pouches there's actually some
debate about this Darwin Darwin
suspected that lungs evolved from float
bladders in fish but we actually now
think
that the the float bladders that fish
use for buoyancy actually evolved from
early lungs and those lungs originally
evolved from just kind of sacs that
developed in the back of the throat
allowing fish - gulp up air when there
was not very much oxygen in the water
you've probably seen this if you've had
a goldfish with when you were a kid and
you weren't changing the water
frequently or you didn't have enough
oxygen in there you'd see the fish
gulping at the top and you're like
whoops is time to oxygenate the water
that that that behavior what they're
doing is they're the gulping up water or
they're gulping up air they're sloshing
it they're mixing it with the water and
pushing that over their gills and
through a structure very similar to that
just a little pouch developing below the
gills you can actually get the evolution
of really primitive lungs where the that
within that pouch there's there's blood
that's very close to the surface of the
skin the the membranes there and that
can absorb oxygen and from that you
eventually get lungs to evolve and
there's still there are lots of fish
that have lungs by the way there's one
fish for example and then finally the
stinger of a bee the sting of a bee is a
moat is a modified ovipositor and the
evidence for this is absolutely
overwhelming an ovipositor is an organ
that insects used to lay their eggs and
you know the only bees that have
stingers are females the worker bees and
a colony are females
the queen bee has a stinger the worker
bees have a stinger the queen bee uses
hers to lay eggs she can also use it to
sting the worker bees only use their of
a positive distinct they no longer lay
eggs the sting of a bee is a modified
reproductive organ of a female insect so
pretty pretty fascinating now what
to do here is answer any questions that
people have so far so if you want to
shoot me out a question here on the in
the comments right now I am now looking
in the live chat
some people are actually asking about
the aquatic a hypothesis is that still
considered likely it is largely rejected
some people you know it's been proposed
that humans a lot of the traits that we
have come because we went through an
aquatic stage and yeah for the most part
people reject that in favor of just you
know living in the savannas yeah someone
says I had a question that I forgot it
well
couple just a minute here for questions
and then we're going to go on to
learning about turtles that breathe
through their butts
see here
okay the the
you're now sleeping okay why isn't that
parrot feather thing just tool used well
I mean it kind of is but by that nature
you could say that you know anything
that any use of our own bodies is tool
use I highly doubt that the the parrot
that's now using its feathers as a back
scratcher I highly doubt that evolution
will actually select and it select that
for that and that will be a major trait
used by parents in the future but this
is just an example of different
individuals finding new uses for
structures that they already have and if
that new use happens that really help
you survive and reproduce natural
selection will favor it and will promote
it and it will become a thing in the
future so that is a possibility for
these parrots I mean maybe if you have a
major parasite infestation in these
parrots that start using feathers to
pluck out those parasites are able to
better survive and reproduce then that
could actually be something strong
enough to wear you know a new feather
structure evolves that may be a really
good back scratcher
that grows rapidly and falls out rapidly
so there's always plenty of them around
something like that could evolve in the
birds but that's you know it's it's a
possibility
all right I am going to move on to
learning about turtles
so start sharing my screen again
all right so this is the Fitzroy River
turtle and it does breathe through its
but it was discovered in the 80s well
probably it wasn't discovered in the 80s
it was first described in the 80s it
lives in Australia the fetch boy River
as where as found and a couple of
interesting facts about its butt
breathing abilities it receives about 70
percent of its oxygen through the cloaca
orifice and it can remain underwater for
up to three weeks without coming up to
surface and catch them get it get a
breath of air so it's it's extremely
efficient you know being a little
standard water for three weeks that's
pretty awesome they don't normally do
that but they can if they have to and
water is pumped in and out in and out of
that orifice 15 to 60 times per minute
so and you know when you watch them in
an aquarium you can you can see that
happen and when it was first discovered
you know there's there's a I'll have to
link to this in the video description
there's a there's a write-up about this
species by John Legler and John can that
was done in that is published in 1980
where they give it the species its name
and describe it really in-depth have a
lot of pictures of it and they they
dissect them and they show their anatomy
but one of the funniest things that I
saw in that and that article I was
reading it is that we first became aware
of the large cloaca l' versi burst I had
just like a name for sac internal sac
the large cloaca bursts I when a female
is examined in bright sunlight the
carapace transmitted enough light to
illuminate the cavity and to produce a
spectacular view internally for at least
100 millimeters I just thought it was
interesting that he called it a
spectacular view of the inside of this
Turtles cloaca so for those that don't
know a cloaca is in reptiles and birds
instead of having you know theirs
sex organs separated from their rectums
they they just have one slit and
everything is inside of there and that's
the cloaca they got the you know and
everything hole that's what it's
sometimes referred to as and how would
you like to see this spectacular
structure well if you don't want to see
look away because we're about to look
and see what this Turtles cloaca looks
like so here we go that is a baby pitch
for a river turtle and that is it's what
they say spectacular that is the
spectacular internal view of his cloaca
so you know exaptation all right here's
another ere picture this is an adult
that they had the one we just saw was a
juvenile this is an adult Fitzroy River
turtle they're really really cool little
animals here's another picture of one
and then there's really cool because
like they're there they're really cute
I'd love to have one they're endangered
however and this is a little diagram
that I found showing kind of the
internal structure of these Turtles and
these giant sacks inside their bodies
and those sacks are filled with villi
and those villi are covered in blood
vessels and they can actually pump water
in and out of these sacs and those villi
and the blood vessels on it absorb the
oxygen and the water and bring that into
the blood system
another circulatory system so it's it's
it's a cloaca gill a cloaca lung and it
breathes oxygenated water so really
really really cool structure and if just
think about all this you need muscles to
power this in order for it to work you
need these sacs order those stacks come
from you need these villi one of those
ability come from all of these really
neat structures that this turtle has it
are they're not completely unique
this turtle other species of turtle have
can do some local breathing but it is
this stream in the fitzroy river turtle
and so this brings us to this question
how on earth did something like this
evolve well turtles already have lungs
and what that means is that because they
already have lungs they already have a
way to get oxygen a safe way to get
oxygen and this allows evolution to
experiment with secondary ways to also
receive oxygen and this is something
that it's really good to point out you
know people ask a lot of times
especially with the evolution of lungs
I've seen this question like how did the
first how did the first animal that came
out onto onto land how did the first
animal breathe like well it actually
already had lungs fish already evolved
lungs long before the first fish came
out onto land and those fish were using
those lungs to gulp up air when they
were in water that was very poor in
oxygen
so if you are a fish from the ocean in
the ocean there's usually an okay amount
of oxygen but when you come into you
know close to the shore and especially
if you go up into little swampy areas
there's a lot of there's a lot of
bacteria and microorganisms that are
using up oxygen and causing the water to
be very stagnant and so fish that are
finding food and resources in these
oxygen deprived areas they're going to
be going in there and it's going to be
helpful the better they are at gulping
up air the more the more efficient their
life is going to be in these oxygen
deprived areas and so fish had gills to
begin with which allowed them to slowly
experiment with the evolution of lungs
and in this case these turtles had lungs
to begin with which allowed them to
start to experiment with the evolution
of a new Gill system and you can imagine
if you live in a river that has a lot of
oxygen in the water the longer you can
stay underwater the better off you are
if you're hunting underwater if you're
eating things underwater if you're
hiding from predators under the water
the longer you can hold your breath the
better off you are
so evolution was able to experiment with
the evolution of these this Chloe chol
Gill in this particular environment with
this species cloaca
tissue so just the the the membranes
inside of our bodies the the mucous
membranes and our bodies are already
very absorbent so you know you know that
the inside of our nose for example is a
mucous membrane and the inside of our
nose is very absorbent a few you know
people people that use there's all kinds
of people use drugs where they snort
them and the reason that snorting drugs
works is because you have this mucous
membrane inside your nose and it can
absorb small molecules really well and
and the same is true with all mucous
membranes we can absorb small molecules
through those mucous membranes
there's blood vessels very close to the
surface and they absorb molecules so the
cloaca tissue you know right inside the
cloaca it's already able to absorb
oxygen in normal turtles in turtles that
have not evolved any sort of a special
adaptation for this they can already
kind of breathe through their cloaca and
the same is true actually with most
turtles just through their skin in
general they can absorb a little bit of
oxygen but especially through those
mucous membranes on the inside of their
body they can absorb a lot of oxygen and
other small molecules through that
tissue so they already had a head start
there this is this is an example of an
exaptation you know the the the the pre
absorbent tissue inside the cloaca in
this case it has adopted a new use a new
function to absorb oxygen from the water
the muscles that help pump the water
through the this new respiratory system
in this turtle those MA
fools are likely just normal muscles
from the digestive system and I should
probably point out here that the actual
evolution of this respiratory system and
turtles has not been well studied and
I've thought for a while you know if I
if I ever were to go and get my PhD in
evolutionary biology the fitchburg River
turtle is what I would study I would
love to be able to figure out all the
details of how this system evolved it's
a really really neat system and the yeah
that would be like my dream research
project because it hasn't been very well
studied we assume that these are just
the muscles of the digestive system that
have been repurposed to pump water back
and forth through the cloaca they're
also still used in - you know when the
animal is relieving itself those same
muscles are still used to expel you know
feces and whatnot but it appears as
though those same muscles have also been
used to allow for cloaca breathing the
the Bur sigh and the sacs that are
inside the turtle's body again we don't
know this for sure because it hasn't
been well studied but they might be
modified sperm storage organs so turtles
do not have most turtles don't form
bonds with partners instead they'll mate
once and the female will store sperm in
her body that she gets from her sexual
partner she'll store it in there and
she'll use that sometimes for years to
come to fertilized eggs
as she's producing eggs and they're
really complex networks of sperm storage
cavities inside a female turtles body
now if this is the case if these
respiratory structures are modified
sperm storage organs this hasn't been
studied it'd be really curious I'm
really curious to know are they still
being used for that are they being used
for that and for respiration because
these turtles still need to store sperm
after mating furthermore why is it that
if they if they really are these sperm
storage organs why are they also found
in males how has that been expressed in
males of course in in humans wheels
males and females both have you know
males have female sex trade so we have
nipples for example which we don't use
to you know suckle children but that's
obviously what they're for
and that's what they're used for in
females but we still have them anyways
is this a similar case where these these
bursts I evolved in females for
respiration and the males got them too
because there's a little bit of
crossover between male and females
traits these are all really interesting
things to study to look into and then
finally the villi inside these these
sacs
could they be misplaced intestinal villi
so in our intestines we have these and a
finger-like protrusions that help absorb
nutrients they give the inside of the
intestine a lot larger surface area and
are the villi inside these these
respiratory sacks in the Fitzroy River
turtle are they just misplaced
intestinal villi and we know that
evolution can do this sort of thing very
easily it's called a homeotic mutation
when there's a mutation in the the homeo
genes that the genes that control other
genes their regulatory genes mutations
in these genes can cause structures to
develop inside of organs where they
don't normally develop so if you have a
structure that evolved in the intestines
for example that can then be expressed
in other parts of the organism due to
homeotic mutations this is something
that's studied in the science of
evo-devo
evolutionary development so we know it's
very obvious that the cloaca Gill is a
modified cloaca so this is definitely a
form of exaptation that's how this
system is evolved
but a lot of the details on this we
don't we don't really know and it'd be
really fascinating to study this so
anyway that is the Fitzroy River turtle
and it's amazing ability to breathe
through its butt
so I want to just go over and answer
some questions here again super chats
are prioritized here let me stop sharing
my screen
all right there there I am and you'll
see if super chats have come in I don't
have any super chats yet
someone says
kazar yuck enough already let's see
someone says
how snorting drugs works know when how
can I be doing that in the stated
casually youtube channel that would now
be keeping this PG right
someone asks can we consider the whale
pelvis bones to be an example of
exaptation they made it more efficient
for mating
in that case no in all mammals the the
pelvis bones are already used for mating
our pelvis bones are what anchor our sex
organs in whales you know so so in a
normal land mammal you've got these
pelvis bones which are used to do a
whole bunch of things you know in humans
since we we walk upright our pelvis
bones act as a shelf to hold in our
organs they sort of do that for animals
that walk on all fours as well but it's
especially important in animals that
walk upright the pelvic bones also
obviously the major function most
obvious function is that they they
support our legs right that that's where
our legs are attached and then the third
big function is that they act as an
attachment for our sexual organs in
whales they've simply lost those other
structures those are their functions so
so whales are using their their it's not
an exaptation really it's just a loss of
a bunch of traits that already that used
to exist
we just got a super chat in from from
Marilyn she says hi John I don't have a
question but I gave you that super chat
just because you okay she's okay she's
gonna make me blush
looking for anymore questions here Thank
You Marilyn by the way
so it looks like people have many
questions so I think we're gonna wrap
this up just kind of in summary new
traits evolve through several different
processes through a gradual evolution by
the way I've got you know I showed you I
showed you the the flat faced dog skull
here this is a normal wolf skull and
hold on let me pull up my camera so I
can see myself here this is a normal
wolf skull compared to a flat faced
dog's skull and then here we've got a
skull that's been kind of angled
downwards and this mutation actually
happened through a slow gradual process
and the dog breeds that have faces that
are sloped downwards
this mutation happened pretty much all
at once and so there's even within dog
breeds there's we can actually see when
we go back through people's
documentation of dog breeding we can
actually see different types of
evolution happening sometimes there's
the hopeful monster style of evolution
where it happens all at once sometimes
it's slow and gradual and breeders are
able to work with tiny mutations and
kind of accumulate those over time so a
lot of a lot of what we know about these
evolutionary processes comes from
selectively breeding plants and animals
and seeing how things work when we're
the ones that are actually directing the
evolution and then we can also go back
to the fossil record and see these
different types of evolution happening
out there and we can look at comparative
anatomy to also try and help us figure
out did this evolve really quickly all
at once or did evolve gradually and
we're now getting to the point and we're
not very good at this yet but we're now
getting to the point where we can start
to look at Justin genes and involved in
a particular trait and that could help
us figure out what
they're not this particular trait
evolved rapidly and a hopeful monster
type scenario or slowly in a very
gradual step-by-step type manner or if
it's an exaptation you know it's is it
using all the genes from a different
organ that we find in other animals was
there a gene duplication and so on now
next week and my I'm going to kind of
continue down this pathway of talking
about how new structures evolve but I'm
going to focus on the genetics behind
all of this because there are some
really really fascinating experiments
have been going on where we can we've
actually done in vitro evolution so in
vitro in in the test-tube evolutionary
experiments with genes that are made out
of just nothing but RNA and you know
today I've showed a lot of how new
functions evolve not really from from
from nothing but they evolved from old
functions but next Sunday I'm going to
talk about how we get these really
interesting genes to evolve from
completely random space so we start out
with genes that are totally random that
their genetic sequence is totally random
and we give them some some obstacles
they have to overcome we let them
replicate in the face of these obstacles
and they'll actually evolve very
specific traits to help them overcome
those obstacles it's really neat we've
been doing these types of experiments
now for 40 years 40 years of in vitro
evolution and that's actually the name
of a paper that I'm going to be going
over in next week's talk so very excited
about that so just looking up for some
last minute questions here so once
that's going to ask something off topic
sure
yeah if you have a question just just
shoot if it's off-topic that's okay
I mean if it's way off topic oh yeah
my Back to the Future t-shirt so it's a
good show full of a great science right
things up there is another live show
going on
Shannon Q's channel she's going to be
interviewing Jordan Culver and for those
of you who don't know Jordan Culver is
an amazing science communicator he does
science comics and sometimes he works
with me to do stated clearly animations
and she's gonna be interviewing him I
don't have a link to that if anyone has
the link to that please put that in the
comment section here someone wants the
resources for molecular evolution yeah I
will put that I will put a link in the
in the video description after I'm done
with the live broadcast here I'll put a
link to that paper I believe there's a
version of it that's not behind a
paywall so yeah I'll link you to that
it's a really good paper it's a it's I
mean it's an overview of 40 years of
this in vitro molecular evolution
experimentation so okay I'll put a link
to Shannon's video in the description
here it looks like she's getting ready
for her her presentation right now so
gonna wrap things up thank you everyone
this was fun it was good times if you
can give the video a like that helps
YouTube rank it better and the once once
this is published because people can
actually watch this video after it's
after the broadcast is over and that
will help so so long for now stay
curious a lot of fun